in a national emergency the country's
leader is normally front and center not
so China's President Xi Jingping his
meeting with a visiting head of the
World Health Organization in late
January was one of his few recent
appearances on state televisions nightly
news where he normally features
prominently and since demanding a
transparent and timely release of
information about the corona virus more
than two weeks ago he's yet to visit
Wuhan instead he sent the Premier Li
Keqiang to test the temperature and
encourage medical workers one analyst
says there's perhaps a good reason for
the president's disappearing act if
things turned bad
I think the owners will be on Nico Chang
and so so in a way sitting ping is as
protected himself from being too much
exposed by that crisis it's almost two
years since she was appointed president
for another five years
that was after China's Parliament voted
to abolish the two-term limit on the
presidency effectively allowing XI to
remain in office for life for President
Xi this crisis is much bigger than the
ongoing protests here in Hong Kong or
trade friction with the United States
because the way his government has
responded to the corona virus outbreak
is causing more and more people on the
mainland to openly question the system
they live under many Chinese people feel
that core values like family livelihood
and food security are now under attack
threatening Xi's credibility and
legitimacy especially if the virus
becomes pandemic so I don't think this
is as bad as that at the moment and he's
got no real competition
you know he's secure but if this sort of
crisis deepens and does become a
pandemic of course the political
consequences could be devastating
a medieval-style virus is threatening
China's city of the future 17 years ago
I reported from Shanghai on the
aftermath of another deadly virus SARS
that also caused people to question
their faith in the party after officials
admitted a cover-up a local colleague
helped navigate me around a popular
chatroom the Internet in China was still
in its infancy then as now though public
skepticism ran deep he said he said Mayo
that means didn't tell the truth he says
the government yeah yeah there are more
expressions of anger today in spite of
tighter internet censorship lessons that
should have been learned from SARS
haven't proof once more the China
remains vulnerable to disease at the
beginning of the crisis China was
boasting I mean these the media were
boasting about the how much the Chinese
political system could better face the
crisis better manage the crisis and
solve the crisis he said it's hard to
imagine the crisis threatening she's
survival because unlike seventeen years
ago China's security machine is much
bigger and better able to maintain
control Adrian Brown al-jazeera
Hong Kong